my dad was like the skeptical one at
first he was like the dad of course and
you know he was like I don't know if
this is you know this is gonna be
possible whatever and then as he's
starting to see that I'm serious about
it and that this is what I want to do
he's like all in he's really shocked
though that everything's kind of
happening he's like I just don't I can't
wrap my head around it
alessia's breakthrough double platinum
single here was one of the most played
tunes in 2015 selling more than 2
million copies in North America it hit
number 7 on Billboard's Hot 100 chart
and clicked its way to over a hundred
and forty five million global streams
just six months after its release what's
crazy that I just you know what got seen
and got discovered and found and people
saw something in me from like the other
side of the world this huge expectation
for women not only in the industry but
just in general in the industry in
specific you're just expected to look a
certain way act a certain way do this
and do that and everything is so overly
sexualized and glorified and I think
like the focus is being placed on the
wrong thing I love that there's young
female artists being talented and being
famous for their talent and what they do
that's the best thing it's such a good
thing to look up to like your famous
friend Taylor Swift who not only invited
Alessia on stage with her but also
interviewed the rising star on Yahoo
music for her debut album one day I was
just sitting in LA in my hotel room and
something just told me to ask her so I
just DM to her this long message like
hey Taylor you know I don't know if
you're gonna see this but and I just
asked her like would you mind
interviewing me from album I don't think
there's ever been a hit song about a
party being lame oh my goodness it was
the best feeling in the whole wide world
to have an artist that I look up to and
just such an influential artists just
say that she believes in my music and
Taylor isn't alessia's only famous fan
Allen Lord Shawn Mendes an even Drake
have all shared their love for the
Brampton Ontario singer I do have
Drake's number and he told me once that
when I covered hotline bling a long time
ago he's like great job so that was that
was cool but I don't know I don't really
have many famous people's numbers in my
phone I don't know I don't talk to
people
[Music]
winning matter to me honestly I know
that sounds like really cheesy and
cliche cuz everyone says it and might
not sound like it sounds good as being
modest but genuine generally I really
just the fact that I'm here and
performing is like the biggest deal for
me well it turns out she did win taking
home Breakthrough Artist of the Year the
2016 Juno Awards and Alessia was still
in shock when we met up with her
backstage I'm still nervous about
something that already happened does
that make you any sense
good thing her mom was on hand to help
with the nerves what's going through
your heart right now she's been
supportive since like before I even
thought I could sing she was always like
you're gonna do this you're gonna be a
musician do you feel like best new
artist no in 2018 unless he became the
first Canadian ever to win the Grammys
best new artist honor in years past
Bieber Drake Shania Feist
and Alanis Morissette have all been
nominated but came up short and
alessia's moment was all the more
powerful because she was the only woman
to win on that year's broadcast
backstage she spoke about the importance
of equality and the times up movement so
yeah the white rose I think for me it
just means speaking up for not only
women in the entertainment industry of
course that you know are treated
unequally but just women who don't have
a voice the end they aren't as lucky to
have a platform like I am and just you
know stating the obvious stating the
fact that things are uneven and unequal
and they need to be talked about it need
to be changed
with the second album there's a lot of
anticipation that wasn't necessarily
there the first time around
unfortunately her sophomore release the
pains of growing received only lukewarm
reviews and peaked at number 71 on the
Billboard 200 but her recent EP this
summer had critics praising Alessia for
embracing a new bouncy and funky sound
something we hope to hear more of on the
next album these get bigger and you go
on in your career are you ever concerned
about losing focus losing who you are
who you've wanted to be I don't know a
lot of things and I'm still figuring out
a million and one things about myself
but I Know Who I am
and that's the most important thing